cast ted florendo is out at circa
working on his backstroke hey ted
we're also the local swim headquarters
too just to let you know
yeah my assignment of course was to
showcase
the stadium swim at the circa and take a
look behind me
it is unbelievable guys an unbelievable
sight
not only for this great amphitheater and
this great great
screen you can see daytime and at night
we're talking uh uh
two solar bars at the lower level 30
cabanas and super cabanas that can host
up to 25 guests
and they'll put out three 337 chase
lounges
along with 38 beds and eight poolside
boxes so you can come up here
do vip status or just sit in the pool
the pool is actually warm get this guys
between 78 to 94 degrees year-round
i was a little hesitant to put my hand
in it i did i was like
wow 92 degrees exactly so we're going to
take you down to the pool a little later
on
showcase that so there's six of them
down here but the view is also
incredible right now we want to show you
your forecast to talk about the high for
the day today yesterday only 59 degrees
today we told you we'd warm up a little
bit
back to the 60s for the day today 45 for
the morning start still a little chilly
for some
but a little better than 41 we had
yesterday
still below average for our temperatures
for this time of the year and nowhere
near that record territory of 92 degrees
no
thank you i think we're done with those
90s for the rest of the year
meanwhile let's take a look at the us
because it's not just us that's a little
on chilly side
the central part of the u.s midwest all
staying on the chilly side in the 30s
even below freezing for some locales
from the plain states down to the big
deal look at the big dec temperatures
same goes for chicago and all that cold
air is going to move its way towards the
east satellite radar does show
the reason for the cold air that uh jet
stream has dipped all the way down to
mexico and within that we have that
system
that's still providing snow for areas in
new mexico and also the texas panhandle
moving along here's your halloween
forecast
81 degrees at 4 pm on halloween and
after that still staying mild 79 for all
those trick-or-treaters that are
actually going to go
out 8 p.m 76 degrees with those dancing
monsters
now we're also tracking tropical storm
zeta uh
it is going to become a hurricane once
again once it
gains intensity over the warmer waters
of the gulf of mexico notice where it's
going to head to
it's going to hit portions possibly
louisiana possibly a florida panhandle
by tomorrow the forecast track has not
changed much
i'm telling you that's a bad spot
because there's still winter or there's
still a hurricane weary out there back
live now as you can see
great shot of the circus screen we'll
talk more about the pool
and